une nouvelle attaque terroriste
islamiste assumée et revendiquée a
provoqué la mort d'un touriste allemand
et blessé deux personnes et le bilan
n'est pas plus lourd grâce au courage de
nos forces de l'ordre à chaque attaque
les mêmes questions car à chaque attaque
on découvre un auteur connu repéré
surveillé et à chaque attaque les
Français déplorent que rien n'a été fait
pour le neutraliser à chaque attaque
aussi nos compatriotes assistent aux
divers médiatique et
politique non la question n'est pas le
suivi psychiatrique mais bien la
neutralisation de quelqu'un dont les
prédispositions idéologiques le parcours
criminel et les revendications sont
parfaitement cohérents l'islamisme n'est
pas regarder en face mais minoré pas
analyser mais
invisibilisé pas affronter mais
contourner et vous faignez d'ignorer
qu'une bonne partie des terroristes est
issue de l'immigration car cela mettrait
en cause les responsabilités passées et
présentes dans la submersion migratoire
que nous
subissons je vous le dis avec gravité et
regret cette dérobade n'est pas
responsable en ce qui nous concerne nous
ne nous déroberons pas nous continuerons
de tenir le langage de vérité et de
fermeté qu'attendent légitimement tous
les français pour combattre l'islamisme
je vous renvoie à ma proposition de loi
visant à combattre les idéologieses la
mise déposée en février
2021 pour combattre les
islamistes nous avons là aussi des
mesures expulser ceux qui sont étrangers
pour menaces grave à l'ordre public ou
terrorisme des choirs de leur
nationalité les binationaux comme c'est
le cas du terroriste du pomirakem puis
les expulser poursuivre les nationaux
pour intelligence avec l'ennemi après
avoir dressé une liste d'organisation
etnemi de la France les solutions
efficaces et dissuasives existent madame
la Première ministre êtes-vous prête à
prendre mesures et à les mettre envre
merci la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Le Pen quand la France est
touchée il y a ceux qui agissent en
responsabilité et puis il y a vous et
votre parti qui une nouvelle fois vous
précipité dans le seul but d'alimenter
les polémiques vous qui ne respectez
jamais le travail des enquêteur et de la
justice et tirez toujours les
conclusions sans même connaître les
faits vous qui remettez en cause parce
que c'est bien ce que vous faites le
travail de nos services de renseignement
et de nos forces de l'ordre alors depuis
2017 madame la Présidente Le Pen malgré
une menace qui ne cesse de se renouveler
et de s'adapter 43 attentats ont été
déjoués 1500 personnes ont été
interpellées et présenté devant la
justice pour des faits de terrorisme et
pendant ce temps Madame la Présidente le
P où étiez-vous où étiez-vous en 2017
avec vos députés lors du vote de la loi
renforçant la sécurité intérieure et la
lutte contre le terrorisme une loi qui
permet de fermer les lieux de culte où
l'on propage la haine et qui facilite
les mesures de surveillance individuelle
vous ne l'avez pas voté où étiez-vous en
2019 quand nous avons créé le parquet
national antiterroriste vous avez voté
contre où étiez-vous en 2021 quand nous
avons créé le délit de séparatisme et
que nous avons étendu le fichier des
auteurs d'infraction aux apologies et
provocations au terrorisme vous ne
l'avez pas voté où étiez-vous quand nous
avons donné des moyens inédits à nos
services de renseignement tous ces
budgets avec vos députés vous vous y
êtes opposé alors madame Le Pen les
faits sont simples le rassemblement
national c'est systématiquement opposé
aux mesures pour renforcer la protection
des Français systématiquement os aux
mesures pour renforcer la lutte contre
le terrorisme nous agissons vous
polémiquez nous prons prenons des
mesures vous êtes dans la posture vos
votes parlent de même nous nous sommes
du côté des actes nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour protéger les
Français je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre